There's a new boss in my life.
You're looking at it.
Yup, it's a desk.
The Stir Kinetic M1 is a standing desk,...
...the kind that gets you up out of the comfy office chair...
...that doctors say can contribute to heart disease and obesity.
In case you haven't heard, sitting is the new smoking.
But this standing desk isn't like the others.
It's part-robot.
All day long, the M1 logs my ups and downs and coaxes me to get moving.
They call it a smart desk.
I also call it a luxury because the M1 costs a cool $2990.
When the M1 wants me to stand up, it starts heaving.
They call this move a whisper breath.
I double-tap the screen and up we go.
My reward for 20 minutes of standing is another whisper breath.
Double-tap, and we're headed back down.
This method is effective.
The M1's makers say that only 30% of people with ordinary movable desks actually use them daily.